منذ البداية لاحظنا أن
أه الرئيس بوتين سيكون مفتوحًا لأي
بديل
يستطيعه وسيكون جاهزًا لعقد
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك وسيكون
جاهزًا لمؤتمر
صحفي خاص به مع
تجمع الحشود وأولئك الصحفيين الراغبين
إذا لم يكن هناك مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
كما تعلم ، يخبرنا
المسؤولون أنه لن يكون هناك ما هو
مخيب للآمال من
وجهة نظر الكرملين
لأنني أعتقد أن أحد الأسباب الرئيسية لفلاديمير
بوتين  أراد أن يذهب ويلتقي بالرئيس
بايدن لكي يظهر
على نفس المنصة ليُظهر أنه
رجل دولة
عالمي ولن تكون فرصة ستُعرض
عليه
بدون مؤتمر صحفي مشترك ،
أليس هذا ليس كذلك؟  ليست قضية على
الإطلاق وهذا ليس هدفًا من قدوم الرئيس
بوتين إلى جنيف ،
فليس هناك أي معنى بالنسبة له لتحسين كونه
رجل دولة عالمي وما إلى ذلك وهكذا دواليك
السبب الرئيسي وراءه هو شخص فقير.
تاريخ العلاقة بين بلدينا
ومستوى حرج لهذه
العلاقة يتطلب
أه يتطلب قمة بين
بلدينا لأن هذا هو السبيل الوحيد
لأه هذا هو السبيل الوحيد لترتيب
تقييم للوضع في
علاقتنا أه ل  لمنع أه
المزيد من
التدهور أه في حوارنا